[Music]
attend the viewers of the super bowl
were delighted to see the second trailer
for doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness on february 13th after
spider-man no way home expectations for
steven strange's second solo appearance
are correspondingly high because here as
the title already reveals the multiverse
open in the loki series is spun further
and treated in more detail find out what
you need to know about the upcoming mcu
movie about doctor strange and what is
already known about the plot the cast
and the production in the latest kino
jack original
let's first discuss the plot of doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
which is why we will first start with a
plot of the first movie from 2016. of
course we must point at this point that
there's a high risk of spoilers for
those who haven't seen the first part in
addition we will also go into events of
one division later here again will be a
high risk of spoilers dr steven strange
starts out as an extremely gifted
neurosurgeon with a huge ego who doesn't
hide his talon from other people however
a tragic car accident causes him to lose
control of his proverbial magic hands
and despite the help of his then
girlfriend christine palmer and the
investment of his life savings in the
experimental treatment his condition
barely improves prompted by the story of
jonathan pankborn a former paraplegic
who was able to walk again after a visit
to camotash strange travels to kathmandu
there he meets the wizard mordo and is
eventually introduced to the elder she
is the supreme sorceress and head of the
comitage and her unusual long life is a
great mystery through her the extremely
skeptical stephen strange learns about
the so-called astral dimension and other
dimensions she also tells him that the
earth is protected by three temples of
the sorcerer agamotto one of which is
the sanctum sanctorum in new york city
the plan of the main antagonist
caesareas during the movie is to destroy
the three sanctums in new york london
and hong kong so that the earth is
pulled into the dark dimension when no
time exists and everyone can live
forever by traveling to the dark
dimension strange convinces the powerful
being dormammu to leave earth alone
through a clever move not without first
banishing casillas and his team to the
dark dimension by using the time pendant
however strange has broken certain rules
and angered to visit mordo the latter
cannot approve of the way the world was
safe from the dark dimension mordo
eventually turns his back on the other
wizard and in the post-credits scene you
can see him attacking pangborn and
draining his power so now you should
know exactly what happened in the first
movie again before we turn to the
potential villains and characters of the
sequel
first let's go to the potential
antagonists of the second movie one of
the most exciting characters besides the
doctors of course wanda maximoff played
here as in the series by elizabeth olsen
as olsen already revealed in an
interview she only learned about the
story of doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness two weeks before
the end of one division in any case it
is essential to have seen one division
before seeing doctor strange too if you
look at the post credit scene of the
very first mcu series for example you
can see her studying the extremely
dangerous darkhold which is also
featured in the new doctor strange
trailer this is a possible sign that she
will mutate into an antagonist over the
course of the events of doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness so it
seems likely that thanks to the darkhold
we will see both the good side of wander
and the evil side of the scarlet witch
another possibility would be wanda from
another universe who could make life
difficult for both doctor strange and
the real wonder either way scarlet witch
is still likely to become a serious
problem in connection with a dark hole
we also think it's likely that mephisto
could make an appearance in doctor
strange too in the comics mephisto is an
extra dimensional demon who rolls over a
blazing hot dimension that he himself
called hell since the dark hole
originated in hell and was also created
from dark matter mephisto's involvement
in a potential scarlet witch appearance
is obvious however we think it's
extremely unlikely that he will be the
main villain as mentioned at the
beginning mordo played by chu del
egyphor is of course at the top of the
list of potential villains his motives
are clear he sees the wizards who don't
match his vision as dangerous because
they are far too powerful and don't shy
away from crossing borders at the latest
the events from spider-man no way home
should have been the straw that broke
the camel's back because doctor
strange's failed spell embodies exactly
what mordor would like to prevent
however it must also be said that
despite his antipathy steward strange
mordo is not a villain per se sure he do
anything to stop wizards who are too
powerful in his eyes but he's not quite
a completely bad guy on the other hand
it is also conceivable that mortal has
his own agenda and doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness for example
that he primarily wants to fight the
out-of-control scarlet witch and that
the hunt for strange is only secondary
we will only be able to see more details
in the finished movie anyway third not
surprisingly is the evil doctor strange
as the main villain this character also
called sinister strange is steven's
counterpart from another dimension and
already played a prominent role in both
trailers he probably won't remain the
only version of doctor strange because a
closer look at the trailer revealed
several versions of strange coming
together through the multiverse but it's
just as conceivable that the very
strangers will join forces to contain
the chaos that's been created or even
take on a much bigger villain last but
not least the tentacle monster gargantus
should be mentioned in the comics this
is a sea monster and an enemy of black
panther ii antagonist neymar since
gargantus has already appeared in both
trailers and as seen in the what if
series doesn't really pose much of a
threat we are not assuming a truly
relevant villain here i'm sure he will
be dangerous to doctor strange at one
moment or another but will probably be
dealt with by the protagonist during the
movie
as already seen in the second trailer we
will not be able to welcome wanda
maximov as a newcomer there's for
example an appearance of sir patrick
stewart as professor x as you can tell
from his unmistakable voice if you've
been paying close attention you'll have
noticed that captain marvel will also
make an appearance in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness however it's
not the well-known carol danvers played
by bree larsen but monica rambo she is
played by teona paris and is the
daughter of carol's best friend rambo
already had her first appearance in one
division where it becomes clear that she
is captain marvel from another universe
and has already gained experience as a
superhero there the storyline is in line
with the marvel comics where rambo
succeeds denver's inner role as cap
marvel in the trailer she can be seen
fighting wanda so it remains exciting to
see how big the role of the new captain
marvel will be of course there are
several other characters who will make
an appearance in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness among others
benedict wong as wong rachel mcadams as
christine palmer shoshil gomez is
america chavez as well as michael
stuhlbarg as nicodemus west
now we would like to introduce you to
another theory that has been circulating
for some time and that many marvel fans
wish would come true in the comics there
exists a gathering called the illuminati
this is originally a seven-member secret
society that has some popular characters
from the marvel universe's members each
representative represents a certain
grouping included are iron man for the
avengers mr fantastic for the fantastic
four neymar for atlantis black bolt for
the inhumans professor x for the x-men
t'challa for wakanda and doctor strange
for the mages
so with the appearance of professor x
speculation is mounting that the
illuminati will show up to hold strange
accountable for his missteps it would be
a fan dream without question however as
we've known since the league from august
2021 the mcu version of the illuminati
could consist of professor x captain
carter boulder the brave monica rambo
and mordo this lineup would of course
fit perfectly with the story of doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
but there's also another theory
according to this we will get to see
none other than tom cruise in the role
of iron man this theory is particularly
pecaned as crews was originally slated
for the role before robert downey jr got
it in the upcoming doctor strange sequel
for example we would then be dealing
with an environment from another
multiverse similar to the sinister
strange we see in the trailer proponents
of this theory see themselves confirmed
especially by the ultron like robots
that leave the bound strange up a
staircase in addition supporters of this
theory want to have seen not monika
rambo's captain marvel but tom cruise in
the armor of superior iron man in the
very brief scene with a fiery figure
however there are also powerful
arguments against crew's appearance one
of them is the fact that due to his
standing in hollywood tom cruise almost
never subordinates himself to other
leading actors since it is quite
unlikely that this evil iron man version
would take a very big role this is also
a strong argument against the mission
impossible star
fortunately production of the doctor
strange sequel has long since been
completed for a long time it was
questionable who exactly would have the
honor of taking a seat in the director's
chair after scott derricks left the
project in early 2020 after he retired
to the post of executive producer
spiderman director and horror icon sam
raimi took over as director filming
finally starred in london at the end of
2020 while the theatrical release was
not in mid-2021 as originally planned
due to the pandemic but only on may 6th
2022
that's it again with our latest original
on doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness what do you expect from the
long-awaited mcu movie and do you think
that the movie can meet your
expectations feel free to write us in
the comments and leave us a like and
subscription if you enjoyed the video
see you next time
[Music]
you